In this video, we're going to be talking about a review for understanding LEDs and how they
work.
Now, let there be a note here that working with LEDs, you primarily want to work with
them when it comes to baking.
You can use them with lumen, but you do run the risk, especially if you're mixing it with
Nettite, of hitting some performance costs.
And you kind of want to avoid that.
Let's go ahead and take a look a little bit at understanding how they work.
And I will be bringing in some caveats here to remind you that, well, as cool as LEDs
are, they are primarily being used and should be used when it comes to baking scenarios.
So the workflow with it, you always want to choose your LEDs wisely.
If I was baking, say GPU baking, and my ICVFX environment required it, and maybe my game
workflow that my, maybe we're porting stuff off out to the iPad or the phone, and we chose
not to use lumen, just be able to control things a little bit better.
I can choose whether I want low quality in Quixel, high quality, and if I was in lumen
to use Nettite.
So all these things need to be determined exactly what you need ahead of time.
It's a bit different when it comes to ICVFX.
You have to actually determine in your stage, what is the priority areas or the hero object
areas and how high those resolutions are going to be based on distance from the camera.
Now I know that changes from week to week and from shot to shot working with the director.
So just keep those things in mind.
You may want to grab a good amount of nanites if you needed based on your decisions, but
not too much.
You don't want to bloat your scene.
You don't want to bring things to a crawl, but you'll at least have the option to import
them if you needed to bring them into your scene.
So just keep in mind, you need to be very deterministic.
And I would recommend on being very strategic on where you place things and try to determine
ahead of time what the goals are and visually what you want to go for.
And again, this does change and you can import these later on too.
Now if you're using LODs, you can actually generate your LODs after the fact.
And that's actually pretty helpful.
So if you bring it in and you determine that you need a few more to represent objects in
the distance, you can totally do that in a baking scenario.
All right, let's go to the next slide.
And in here, let's go and talk about a bit of controlling your LODs.
Now again, this is a bit of a review from some of the other classes, which talk about
working with LODs.
But I'm going to dive a little slightly deeper in the fact that I'm going to point out some
things that you can do and you can control for your environment.
So let's go and hop into Unreal and take a look at a few things.
So here in Unreal, I'm kind of breaking the norm here.
I have several different versions of types of geometry here.
I have one that is LOD, another one is Nenite.
Again, that's not typical and you do need to be prepared and watch out for any performance
hits.
But I'm basically for lecture purposes, I have two different kinds.
So this one out here in the distance, let's actually look at the magnifying glass here
with a folder.
And we'll see that we have one that is Nenite.
That's this particular one.
And one that is not.
And automatically, you'll know exactly which one is which, simply by clicking and seeing
which one is active.
So this one's using LODs.
Let's double click on this one and take a closer look.
Now again, when working with LODs, you want to work with it primarily with a baking scenario
because it educators to it and you have less of a problem when it comes to generating your
virtual shadow maps and Lumen.
And overall, the performance is been made in such a way so that Lumen, virtual shadow
maps and Nenite all work together smoothly.
So if you do a mixed bag, you could run into some problems.
Just remember that.
So say we're in a GPU baking scenario here.
So working with this, I have things set to an LOD auto.
Now in here, we have one, two, three, four, five.
We can determine these and choose these in our settings.
So you can see that they're all in here.
And at any time, if I wanted to, I can custom these and isolate the ones that I don't want.
And Unruh will shuffle accordingly to my needs.
So working in here as we scroll down, let's actually close some of the material options
here.
So I can see that we have the LODs we can choose from and edit as we clicked on that
custom.
Allow me to switch materials if I need to, control my triangles.
And because we have auto, custom compute distances, I now have, I can control exactly
what the distance is on things going to be drawn.
And that's actually kind of nice to be able to have that.
You'll see we have triangle control, percentage triangles, max triangle count for each set
of LOD that I have in place.
The only problem or the thing you should look out for in this particular case when working
with it, and this is mainly for reduction, you need to determine exactly what it is
your LODs are sitting at.
And you'll see here the percentage per triangle is set up nicely by default.
If you change these, you need to remember what these numbers are.
So keep those things in mind if you decide to change those as we go.
As I move my camera out and in, you'll see the LOD zero to LOD one, to LOD two, to LOD
three, all set up pretty nicely.
And Unreal does a really good job of setting this up in defaults to be able to actually
control what's happening.
Now, again, you can customize this if you want to or not.
As you notice, I close it, all those other options go away.
So you can control the max.
You'll notice you can also control it on the lumen front, you can control the max lumen
cards for that object.
And that actually can be pretty helpful.
That's a quick note.
That's something I'll bring up later on when we get into lumen and lighting optimization.
So you can also control the group.
What this is, it allows Unreal to get a head start.
And what your intentions are, is this a foliage object?
Is it high detail?
Is it a large prop?
And Unreal will actually try to adjust things according to that object in 3D space.
So it kind of just gives you a quick heads up.
Now it isn't like a all sweeping, amazing.
It'll get you a great large head start, but it actually helps Unreal calculate and know
exactly what your intentions are for that object.
Now you can choose the number of LEDs ahead of time too.
We have five.
Once you increase this number, you want to apply your changes and it will be set in there.
All these things can be done as well as you loading your own LEDs for import.
So if you need to actually swap them out, you can re-import a new version that you have.
It'll actually re-import existing, but you can also choose which ones that you need and
want.
So it's nice to be able to do this at any time and even build out your system.
So if I go back to custom here, you'll notice as I bring in custom, we actually have some
of our scenes such as screen size ready to go.
Now you'll notice the screen size is grayed out.
So this is necessary to be turned on.
To do so, you actually have to turn off your auto compute.
So you'll see auto compute down below.
If I turn this off, you'll notice now that the production or I should say screen size
control is now available.
So I can choose how much percentage on that screen size I'm going to do with these properties.
It's basically an override to say, hey, I want this to show up at a particular time kind
of.
You can think of it that way.
So this is all controllable within here.
We also have the ability to colorize and look at how things are being sorted.
It's probably best that we do this in Unreal outside of the mesh editor.
So let's go ahead and turn that on.
So I'm going to go to my view modes here.
And we're going to go down to our level of detail colorization.
And we're going to go to mesh LED colorization.
You'll again see some that are grayed out because they're already in Nenite.
But for the most part, you'll see it pop in and out through the different color levels
of detail.
It's actually pretty cool, but it shows you then that it's working and sorting according
to what you need.
I just can't drive right now.
So if we go forward, you'll actually see it pop in and out and it's sorting through the
levels of detail.
Again, if you missed where I clicked on it, it's under lit.
And then we have level of detail colorization and you can put that on.
That's it with this one.
In the next video, we're going to be talking about merging geometry and looking at that
up close.
Thanks again.